I'm having a great deal of, ooh, that already put that question down.
I have a wonderful client who is an aerobatic doctor and I asked her what she thought about
my Cyrex array 10 showing so many foods that trigger antibodies.
She said from an aerobatic perspective, my body is going through an autoimmune response
because pathogens in my case cancer cells are being killed and my organs are having a hard
time getting rid of the debris.
She recommended a herb called Tituspora cordopholia, just wondered if your thoughts on her interpretation.
Well, this is Dice rhetoric, the fact that you have antibodies to different foods couldn't
be from endotoxins that are produced when cells die through cell lysis that you have a
more of a hyperimmune response.
So therefore, you are developing antibodies to different foods, maybe, yes, that's possible.
You could have saved it, it's like if you had an infection in your gut in this huge inflammatory
response and now you develop antibodies to foods, but it doesn't change the fact that
you have antibodies to those foods.
The, could it be that your gut is fairly healthy and it is totally because of the cancer
die-off, maybe, I just do not believe that's true, why would everybody that has cancer die-off
and what the same day you'd have all this bloating and all these issues?
So the fact is that once you have antibodies to food and you're exposed yourself to that
food, meaning you eat that food, you're causing more inflammation and you're damaging,
you've got any inflammation in the intestinal lumen is going to cause damage to the intestinal
epithelial cells.
So and then that is a running cascade or cyclical spiral downward because then that causes a
intestinal permeability and then that causes your body to allow different peptides and different
foods to cross the gut border that shouldn't and then that causes your immune system to create
antibodies against it, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that's how you're in the situation, still the bottom line is you got to heal the gut.
So I'm not sure, I don't know enough about that product to sort of different herbs, certainly,
but don't think they'd be hard taking it so.